[__] me
i can't go again suddenly
we gotta go bro i'm not the energy man
come on
mind over matter you quit doing it
around you quick
i've been putting off making this video
for about three [__] years
last year video i made people loved it
they wanted more and i just haven't done
one
for all that time i was gonna say i
don't know why i don't know why it's
because i haven't been going to the gym
a lot you know i have been a little bit
but like you know
phoning in and i haven't been looking
after myself
mentally or physically and i've just
realized that
the only way i'm gonna [__] do this
is if i put some of this out there
if i've got to do this in front of a
load of people i'm more likely to eat
salads
so you [__]
here it is got it
got it
ah [__] you okay come on block
[__] i feel like i'm making mistakes no
i'm not what it is you get more
technical
what's that
that's what's happening
all right move off
beautiful okay
[Music]
don't give me dead ground and that's why
i would love to see you spa
because you'd understand why i say that
don't give me that dead ground
don't give me that dead ground timing
rather than power
yeah do it again
okay there we go [__] sake that's
what i'm putting it up
get me back that's it don't let me out
my way
that's it better
oh
that's what i'm talking about all right
all right all right that's what i'm
talking about
let's do it four six
six six
eight okay
oh
mental strength 16 come on
ready 18.
keep going keep going 20 last one wanna
oh
always [__] one again all right ready
[Music]
ready
i would say he's coming on nicely
he's sharp um he's eager to learn
and that's one of the vital ingredients
having that hunger and that enthusiasm
to learn
and he learns very quickly he learns
quickly
and i'm not saying if he's coming along
he learns quickly and he punches very
hard very hard indeed thanks schmidt
thank you
trisha you've managed to wreck one of my
fingers
this finger here i cannot bend his
finger really yeah
so i mean i'm happy about that that's
good
i think the realization that i need to
sort myself out came after corvid this
year because
i'd had about a year of just being
mentally rock bottom
and a lot of you know about this who
watched the podcast i'd been drinking
and i didn't care about myself at all
yeah i'm sad you know i mean it's just a
very sad it's sad to
uh realize how
i feel inside right now and um it's
difficult
yeah and uh you know i have good days
and bad days it's not like i'm i'm
feeling like it's
uh the end of the world but there's just
some days it does do you know what i
mean so i'm just it's like anyone who
has depression
and then corvid hit me as well and like
a lot of people didn't really know about
corvid when i got it it was like
beginning of february late january i
didn't know what the [__] i was facing
the coronavirus
is the biggest threat this country has
faced for decades
someone's not been well i've been quite
ill as you may be able to tell by the
side of my voice and i'm like
[__] me this flu is awful and i'm
thinking i'm [__]
i feel like i'm dying here like i've
never sweated i'd never
[__] had those aches those pains like
i
cuffed so much in those two weeks that
for a week after that two weeks
i had rib pain like mike tyson had body
shot at me a hundred times like i just
never know an illness like it and when
you are that ill you sort of
you really regret you're like oh [__] i
should have been healthy what the [__]
it was like every chocolate every greasy
food every beer
i drunk was sort of coming back to haunt
me and it's like [__]
you're going to pay for that now [__] i
felt terrible
it's actually quite a nice frame
i don't i'd rather not
the first thing i did to sort myself out
was i went back to weightlifting go with
what you know you know what i mean it's
not too hard
i can push heavy weights around that's
fine and then i added a diet into it
the keto diet everyone was swearing by
it basically the ketogenic diet is where
you drop carbs completely from your diet
your body uses your fat stores to power
it instead and then you lose a lot of
weight
now what they didn't tell me was that
after a week
i'd feel like i was dying it made me
feel
terrible and then someone was like oh
yeah that's the that's the keto flu
sorry what so you decided to start a
ketogenic diet you're gone through a few
days all of a sudden you feel like crap
you start getting tired and dizzy and
lethargic
you know the headache the dizziness the
fatigue the keto flu keto flu keto flu
keto flu keto flu
keto flu ketogenic flu yes the uh you
start
having flu like symptoms it means it's
working i'm like just gotten over
one actual flu don't really want another
one thank you
i just miss mashed potato okay it's
really
really hard but i stuck with the
weightlifting
so every cloud
weir lifting's been in my life for as
long as i can remember my dad was a
bodybuilder
so when he would come into school i mean
like
all the other dads you all look like
dads what's that in the corner looks
like a [__] t-rex yeah
that's my dad like i love the fact that
i have the biggest strongest art
it's sad but when you're a kid you're
like yeah that's sick
so growing up to be big and strong was
something i was just like yeah
absolutely and
then when you get into like wrestling
and [__] like that you see the rock
and you're like
that's cool i want to be a big strong
dude too and then i got into
weightlifting
and i was looking at people like dorian
yates who was a bodybuilder and brock
lesnar and these larger than life
characters
being strong was just something i always
wanted to be
i'm having this press it here instead of
like
here i'm not in line yeah because my
head's there
yeah so i'm sort of what i might be
better off doing is going a bit more
like that
yeah yeah when i first walked into a gym
i was about 19
and i'd done a little bit of training
beforehand like you know swimming and
running and i did used to run believe it
or not once i discovered like what i can
i can move this way really fast and
it'll make me stronger which will then
make me look bigger in the mirror
and women might like that on the night
like this is mental this is
this is fantastic all the fuck-ups i was
making at the time were quickly
corrected by a group of old dudes
because they were i'm like
shaking on the bar and they're like son
shut the [__] up come here and
sit down they schooled me on how to live
properly and drop the ego
and actually do things correctly and
they give me the skills to
basically turn myself into a beast
nice easy
after a couple of years of training
really hard i remember there was one day
i just i was putting the [__] on and the
shirt just fit as
you know the first time i felt like i'm
growing into a [__] man yeah i'm
like you know when you're building your
cell up before a night out and i'm just
looking in the mirror on my titan
i'm like yeah i felt really good about
my the way i looked
and i want to be completely wrong and
completely honest in this and say
it's been a long time since i've felt
that way
about how i look and
that is [__] yeah
leverage so i need to i'm sure
and then make space don't push me off
too far because then
you're gonna get bang all right okay
okay so a little bit it's an
art form notice where my head is notice
where my head is
yeah and my arms
[__] you now you see look this is an art
form and it's it's dead now yeah
this art is dead
rebel durant
you guys are a couple of big ones in the
belly there
ah i must be [__] mental
when it all started to go wrong for me
was in my mid to late 20s
just before i started youtube i had the
worst depression
you know real real bad people i loved it
died
it i didn't care about myself anymore i
stopped going to the gym after being
obsessed with it
for a whole year not when you stopped
going the gym i stopped
getting haircuts i stopped caring about
how i looked and
my drinking was bad at that point and i
wasn't drinking because i was an
alcoholic i was drinking because i
didn't want to feel
anything so much sure that i remember on
a random night i just went through a
whole
case of guinness just cause you know
just because
i was 25 stone so in that yeah i'd gone
from 19 stone to 25 stone
that's when you know you don't care
about yourself
[Music]
yeah that's it strike with the legs make
sure the glutes
head height five forward
[Music]
is
all right this is the money shot
hopefully
[Music]
um
[__] there what are you thinking
about killing someone
[Laughter]
i love it there was a lot of laws around
that time but the one that always
springs to memory was a night out i had
now
i was doing the case of guinness because
it was a tuesday so you can imagine
what my nights out were like they were
the [__] tits but i was paying
the price with my body so i get home
from a night out and i'd [__] been
eating i'd been doing everything you
shouldn't be doing
and i'm leaning over a [__] toilet
and i can't throw up and it's but i can
feel it coming i'm like i'm [__]
gonna throw up here what the [__] is
going on
i'm confused next thing i know is lodged
in my foot and throat and i'm like
i'm gonna i feel like i'm choking just
remembering it it was
[__] horrible so i'm reaching like
god i'm doing everything i can to throw
up i can't throw up and now i can't
breathe
and i'm really [__] panicking like
when you are that [__] and
you're that drunk as well you're that
much of a mess
all of a sudden you're trying to sober
the [__] up it is horrible
i don't know how the [__] i survived
that because i really thought
this is it like this might not seem that
dramatic because i'm just throwing
but it was i was for the longest time
i couldn't [__] be sick and i
couldn't breathe
i can't understand how i managed it
finally i push it out and then i just
collapse on the [__] floor [__]
hell
i knew i thought i cannot continue
taking the piss like this
[Music]
so
free
[Music]
well done quality take a breath
nice one
[Music]
so
true
you know when i entered youtube i had
this big aggressive
confrontational geordie style you know
does my drinking defend you
no one knew that i was quite a sensitive
caring funny person
they see that one clip of me going
mental about newcastle
and that state that's all you are and i
get it like you know but that's haunted
me to this day
some people have still not understood
that i'm not just that one thing you
know what i mean and when you come out
with an attitude
it comes back at you so the comments at
times were
[__] terrible i mean they're telling
me you big
fat jordy cut you know and in my head
i'm like yeah yeah that's what i am and
when you have such a negative feeling
about yourself and you're
battling depression when you have
thousands of comments saying that it's
just reinforcing what you already think
now don't get me wrong it wasn't
crippling me that they were saying that
but it was
not great for me at the same time but on
the other side
youtube was a place where you know i'm
currently in a situation where i've got
to risk my life
in diving and make money this could be a
way out this could be something i could
do something i love i love creating i
love
making videos and i don't just want to
make these football videos and one day
i could maybe have a set of like joe
rogan you know maybe i could
work my way into a situation where i can
make my dreams come true
and i've done that but the one thing i
haven't done
is fix my mental health and my physical
health
and that is what this year is all about
i'm not saying
i'm gonna sort it i'm saying i'm gonna
start trying because this [__] is a
a lifelong battle now and it's been that
way i've just never
took the challenge on now i'm taking the
challenge on
nervous about it or what no i was like
more just trying to think about how to
be better than last time
if someone said you've got one round the
box i think i could and i knew i could
dump all the energy i think it would be
i'd be light on my feet but it's because
i can't
last the test the time really
and i go like this what you're going to
throw there you go
one two three four
down get upset with yourself perfect
feeling oh yeah million percent but
you're not gonna learn it i keep telling
you it just takes years to learn
[Music]
good
come closer
okay
good shots
all right you're getting tired now hold
your feet
this is where your defense comes in
get your breath back so hot
suffering yet horrible what's the
temperature of the deal lauren
wait seven minutes six thirty seven
degrees
this is the hottest day pretty much in
history in the uk
so
[__]
which
shhh
okay
yeah that'd be nice [__] me
i can't guarantee any secondly
i need a bit of a i [__] gave a lot
there i'm on semi
you got go i swear
around a quick turn around you got it
come on
we now have to go through this [__] come
on come on
come on
works
what that's what i want to say oh
oh
one more i [__] got one there right
in the ribs
hard note there just standing there
[__] getting [__] up
there was a couple right in the
bread basket in the ribs
just got any energy
[Music]
just gonna keep moving
it's so hot i'll put that my foot in
here and just note
last round that's a really comfortable
oh
what
i'll do
[Music]
this is hard
cheers
just had a note left for my three rounds
there i've just got to start and then
punches basically
don't know how i've been throwing off
because i feel like
i just wanted to walk him around and
then feel it
i wanted him to know that he's strong
that's all in the mind
it's all in the mind and uh he was ready
to quit
he saw that he didn't quit your mind
just quit
you're only 40 there it's like
standing up becomes a real cho when you
see someone just like
out on the feet just trying to stand up
it's like that you imagine trying to do
that when you're 22 [__] stoned it's
crazy
i don't know what the [__] i'm thinking
with brian he progresses fast he learns
very quick to learn
and um he's hard on himself
which i said to him don't be too hard on
yourself because
it becomes counterproductive hopefully
in a few months
we'll get him some proper fault contact
sparring
but i'll make that decision i'll know
when he's ready
you know as i said repeat myself
he's progressing an alarming rate so
yeah that might come sooner rather than
later i mean we had a conversation
last week and he said to me if i don't
do it now
which means get fit now do what i want
to do now which is boxing
he said um i'll never do it you know
when i get to when he gets to my age
he said well you know i won't be able to
do what you do
so that's because you've kept active you
made the decision at the right time
i'm proud of him for that
you're not supposed to look pretty when
you're [__] training right
you're supposed to look ugly mean and
nasty trust us
if you're [__] look gorgeous when
you're training you're not [__]
training you're [__] posing for
instagram you [__]
it's lovely yeah come in man i'm coming
so what does that say sorry i told you
about determination well done nice thank
you
you've done a lot better you're cutting
the angle you had me pinned up on stage
yeah i felt really proud of that yeah
the problem is i gave too much
that was everything that was basically
my me
yeah i i was like [__] me i've actually
got a hold of him yeah so i just thought
do what your shoulders dig me head in
the chest press that well
yeah i thought that was good i but
before that as well
uh there was a couple of things we did
where i was like all right i'm putting
these combinations together
really well at times obviously not every
time so i'm happy though you've done so
much four weeks
yeah yeah pretty controlling the center
of the ring
you're cutting me off no i didn't bother
doing that exactly i definitely stood my
ground a bit better
but um once i get fit you're [__] it
yeah i've got
oh you got a beautiful right hand yeah
that backhand of yours is a powerful
tool
yeah i'm going to reveal something to
you today how many minutes do you
usually do
round time two minutes how many rounds
did we do today
roughly nice is it nine rounds seven how
many rounds did we do today
i think it might have been i think it
was eight rounds yeah well we've done
you've done three minute rounds today
it felt like
there's a few ways in which i'm going to
do this one is weightlifting i want to
go back to my bread and butter
but not just go back to what i've done i
want to take it further than i've ever
taken it before if i can
i have got a naturally strong body i'm
very very gifted but i've never
really pushed it i want to see when i'm
still young enough when i'm still strong
enough
how many miles per hour we can get out
with this thing that i've been given
while i can i love weightlifting you
know it's in me
it's in me blood we can do some good
things on this channel i think we can we
can put some sick videos out
i want to help some of you guys i want
to show you what i do
how i train maybe show some of the
younger lads out there this is how you
can get started
in terms of the diet uh is chocolate bad
for you
no it's like i'm terrible i am [__] a
diet news flash true jordy bad at diet
and i know
it's not a shock like clearly when
people say to me oh it's 70 percent the
diet i'm like
you're not helping you know can we say
it's 70 the weightlifting because i can
do that
i'm terrible at dieting and it's not
because i don't like healthy food it's
just
convenient food is usually bad for you
and mcdonald's is the most convenient
food
and yes i like a big mark i do actually
like a [__] big mac
judge me if you must okay
there i said it so i've got a lot of
work to do on the titans ain't got a
[__] clue
cardio wise the same as the time
oh for [__] sake i bought a treadmill
ryan oh and there it is
the thing that's gonna fix my cardio he
said as you can see it's getting
a lot of use and this is honestly true
right i'm not saying this for the video
i haven't plugged it in after two weeks
all right it's been gathering dust
just does that offering a little bit
because that's
yeah it's a good few weeks that's the
problem there
that's sorted it sorted it so
great it's partly because i'm not
[__] knockout off of deadlifting and
off of boxing and stuff
i know this sounds like an excuse you're
gonna have to get used to this we will
switch the
treadmill on and i will use it at some
point
that's coming soon treadmill episodes
are gonna be fantastic
as for boxing i absolutely love it
there you go thank you that's it
hey you know you know weightlifting is
all well and good but weights don't hit
back
like you know derek vidal's dad who's uh
helping us
he heads back and this guy can punch so
you know
uh it's fun
oh sorry yeah
yeah oh was impressed
you know when you get in there and he's
teaching me all the technique and
i really appreciate the information and
knowledge that you get passed
down from someone like that you know
it's fascinating and i hope it makes me
better at reading fights in future so
that i'm not as big of a casual
um you know and i'm not trying to be the
next youtube [__] boxer i'm too old
for that [__]
but i just want to learn it for my own
mental health as well as physical health
because it is
you get such a buzz off of it you know
and um
and speaking of mental health i think
that's the last thing on my list is to
just talk to someone
about my mental health so that's the end
of the first five weeks
and [__] hell it was hard it wasn't
even
just the training i mean the training
was bloody hard at times and especially
at the start i mean
just getting out of bed i was out of
breath you know i mean i was so unfit
and there was some of the sessions where
i was like what the [__] i mean
you know i really wanted to give up and
my back was aching i had to go to a
chiropractor just to get like
my back crack and stuff because i was
just stiff as a [__] steel rod
but honestly that isn't the hardest bit
the hardest bit
is when you are mentally low
and you are used to just staying indoors
all day and not
doing a workout or if you're feeling
like you're having a [__] day
avoiding people or whatever you feel
like you need to do
to then push through that in a guy in
the gym or to go to the boxing club
that's the hard bit more than anything
is is when you feel like [__]
forcing yourself to do something it's
difficult that's the being the hardest
bit for me so
um i'm pretty proud of myself
not saying i've climbed mount everest
you know i'm certainly not at the end
goal
and i'm not going to change all of a
sudden into someone who [__] loves
themself but at the start of this five
weeks ago i was 23 stone
i'm now 21 stone that's pretty good
yes i'm sure my phone wasn't perfect on
everything before you get your comments
in
and i probably look like [__] at times
in the box end most of the time because
i'm just learning
but i did it i tried and i'm going to
keep trying
so from now on i'm going to put maybe a
gym video out once a month on the second
channel so
subscribe to tg2 if you want to see more
stuff like this and then
in six months to a year we're going to
come back and i'm going to show you
how i ended up where it went the highs
the lows
everything subscribe to the trujillo
youtube channel if you like this video
hit the like button
thanks for watching to everyone who
supports me big love
and i'll see you later
[Music]
you